when did you first hear the Grinch story
I can't remember but I it the minute the
offer came through I knew who he was and
I know the story very well so some point
some point in my youth I heard and knew
of the Grinch I liked all of dr. Seuss's
stories I think I remember the cat and
hat even better they're so impactful
there so memorable and that's their
design both through the language and the
illustrations they're really catchy that
brilliant for young kids and you know
new readers to encourage their literacy
and enjoyment of stories and narratives
and stuff that we're hardwired to to
consumers as humans so yeah a very
iconic character and I loved him from
the first first minute whenever that was
that I first encountered him so when
they offered me the role I was like um
yeah do you do use any of the old
versions in your performance as a Grinch
no because I didn't see I had never seen
the old versions I think I've seen a
clip of the Boris Karloff cartoon I
remember the trailer for the Jim Carrey
movie but it's a bad idea I think if
you're an actor playing a new version of
an old character that's already been
played by other people to watch other
people's work because it could influence
you you might end up copycatting which
could get into trouble with lawyers
apart from anything else you know angry
carry fans and it's just not a good look
not good look at all listen I don't know
maybe I have copied them accidentally
it's such an iconic character I'm sure
at some point we all made similar
choices but one of the joys of it being
done is I can now go back to those
versions and watch them as well how do
you relate to your character in any way
possible oh well you know I can get
pretty grouchy Grinchy grumpy Green when
I'm hungry angry tired
jet-lagged all of which can happen very
quickly in these interview situations
but I'm going to try and keep my
immigrants in sight he's not gonna come
out you seem like a very positive and
happy person so I can hardly see that
the coffee's working that's all I can
say yeah do you have a Cindy Lou in your
life many thank goodness I'm
nice nd lose many people who remind me
of the joy of life and stop me from
getting miserable or grumpy or
self-obsessed what was your favorite
character in your movie in my movie it
would have to be the Grinch yeah it
would be a Mac should get a shout-out to
he's pretty amazing I think if everyone
had a max the world would be a much
calmer place yeah and um what was your
favorite favorite favorite part about
Fred about about Fred yes
his odd obsession with whipped cream you
know yeah highly pressured whipped cream
going in and out of his nostrils that's
my favorite part
no I in all seriousness his loyalty to
his family it's got to be yeah breaking
when they reunite I loved I loved Fred
he was so it's just so like I'm so glad
that they added it because it's just
it's just he's kind of like max yeah
he's just like the pause it's with the
Grinch who's like really negative but
then Max and Fred are like good there
are the Cindy losing his life really
aren't they there are the good
influences positive influences um did
you so was max when you when like Max
was doing a voiceover is there a real
dog or was it just standards yeah we had
a real dog just sitting there you know
nothing about no of course I may not be
crazy now so I mean it was this was over
two years and there were two month
breaks between each time and I never got
I saw an illustration of Max at the
beginning and that was it I think I saw
a little bit of animation maybe two
thirds of the way through of max but I
was imagining max for that whole time
okay what do you like to do on Christmas
day just be with friends and family shut
the door to the world or going be with
other friends and their families and
just enjoy all together but yeah
basically all other demands and all my
time and all other things of
responsibility fade away and it's all
about family in France
um so Cindy Lou is the sweetest kindest
little girl ever but when he when the
Grinch comes into her house if you were
like you're definitely not but let's
just say you were the Grinch what would
be your excuse for going into her house
quite awkward it would be to make sure
that the chimney was clean yeah
it's important you want a smoky fire on
Christmas Day that can that can ruin a
lot of good times you know everyone
coughing in the eyes watering Elena's
get hot so yeah I'd be yeah I'd be in
the chimney sweep when did you first
hear about the Grinch story well I first
heard about it when I was very young
because my dad used to read me all sorts
of different dr. Seuss books and he read
me the Grinch and he also and we also
liked to watch the movie together have
you seen the the original version like
from way back in like the 60s the I side
- yeah I've seen it it's it's a lot
shorter than it than this one but yeah
and it's very it's very different like I
watched it after I watched this movie
and it's so different yeah but um I
noticed that I haven't read the book
surprisingly but I noticed that some of
the some of the lines were like the same
like maybe that his head's wasn't
screwed on right and then his shoes were
too tight yeah
so they they I think they took some of
the same ones but it's very good um what
does it like being in the sound boost
when you're doing the voiceover it's a
really weird at first because you're
alone with only did the director and
foam surrounding you and a little door
in the corner but after a while you get
kind of used to it because you walk in
and you know exactly what you're gonna
do and where are you gonna go and how
it's gonna work
and sometimes the director wasn't even
there sometimes he was on skype so
sometimes I just have most of the time
honestly I'd have to go into the room
and I'd be alone
the room with the TV in front of me with
the director um so we know that the
Grinch has an adorable dog named max do
you have any dogs
yes I actually got a dog only a week ago
really uh-huh
and his name is Tex he's from Texas he's
a rescue so that's why his name is Tex
we're not really sure he's a mutt so is
he bigger well he's only about six
months so okay he's pretty big for his
age though okay well it was great to
meet you and great interview you you too
thank you so much thank you
you